Kevin Love has reached the NBA finals in
every playoff appearance he has ever
been in let that just sink in and now
let's go down memory lane it's 2015 and
K-LOVE is on the Cavs he wasn't around
to help them out because he was injured
lost in five games against the Warriors
then the Cavs made it to the finals in
2016 facing the Warriors again and beat
them the Cavs went on to play The
Warriors the next two years as well by
the way people don't talk about how
crazy it was that Cleveland and Golden
State were in the finals four years in a
row but anyways Kayla fell short again
in 2017 and 2018. now he's back new team
new colors we think K-LOVE will get his
second NBA Finals trophy